on the morning of August 9 2014 Wilson
tried to detain 18-year-old Michael
Brown who had just robbed a convenience
store and attacked the store clerk and
that's when according to the Obama doj
quote Wilson and other Witnesses stated
that brown reached into Wilson's SUV
through the open driver's window and
punched and grabbed Wilson investigators
made the determination by observing
quote bruising on Wilson's jaw and
scratches on his neck the presence of
Brown's DNA in Wilson's collar shirt and
pants and Wilson's DNA on Brown's poem
Brown then tried to grab Wilson's gun
Wilson shot him Brown ran away then
turned around and charged at Wilson and
Wilson fatally shot Brown in
self-defense